[Musik]
phoenix persönlich der streit um die
zölle bedroht den welthandel der streit
zwischen europa und den usa
die welt auch bei mir ist friedrich merz
den sich sehr herzlich begrüße sehr groß
sind die verantwortlichen eigentlich
nicht mehr in der lage probleme zu lösen
oder sind die probleme zu komplex naja
man kann auch sagen die verantwortlichen
sind sozusagen ein spiegelbild der
probleme das sehen wir ja auch in
amerika ich war einer der wenigen der
nicht wirklich überrascht war von der
wahl von kramp ich war über die
nominierung überrascht in der
republikanischen partei aber dann hat
doch sehr viel darauf hingewiesen dass
eine mehrzahl der wähler bereit ist kaum
zu wählen und das ist ein spiegelbild
der diskussion über globalisierung über
verpasste chancen
amerika ist schon seit längerer zeit in
einem geradezu aufgewühlten zustand und
insofern sind die politiker in amerika
und auch in europa spiegelbild der
probleme in den ländern
wir haben ja täglich neue meldungen über
den amerikanischen präsidenten der auch
deswegen meldungen produziert weil er
sich selber produzieren über twitter
jetzt möchte er sich auch noch in die
deutsche politik an und spricht darüber
wie denn die deutschen streiten aber das
asylrecht
gibt es denn gar keine grenzen mehr gibt
es gar keine formen mehr miteinander
umzugehen
na ja also ich bin wahrscheinlich nicht
der richtige adressat um diese frage
abschließend zu beantworten aber ganz
offensichtlich hat der amerikanische
präsident ein völlig neues format
installiert um mit der öffentlichkeit zu
kommunizieren
er braucht keine medien mehr als
sozusagen vermittler sondern er macht es
über tweets selbst wendet sich damit an
die öffentlichkeit so wie es ihm gerade
gefällt und was ihm gerade einfällt und
das hat etwas undiszipliniertes und das
hat etwas spontanes eruptives
sprunghaftes aber das war klar als tramp
zum präsidenten vereidigt wurde
schon seine einführungsrede hat deutlich
gemacht wohin die reise geht und macht
ja im übrigen etwas was wir
leicht von politikern gar nicht mehr so
gewöhnt sind er macht das in der
regierung was er im wahlkampf
versprochen hat ist ja alles keine
überraschung das was er jetzt macht sind
seine wahlkampf versprechen aus dem
wahlkampf in den usa
und insofern müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass geht weiter das geht
weiter und das große problem ist ja dass
er sozusagen die vereinbarungen
untereinander auflöst die interessieren
ihn ja nicht mehr wir haben ja bei g 7
gesehen dass er nicht mal mehr das
schlussdokument mitunterzeichnet hat das
gab es so weit ich weiß noch nie ist das
eine auflösung der ordnung die im
zweifelsfall auch neue chancen eröffnet
oder ist das eine auflösung die in ein
völliges chaos hinein auch dass wenn ich
sie korrigieren darf war keine
überraschung schon das letzte g 7
finanzministertreffen als deutschland
gastgeber war in baden baden hat kein
schlussdokument ermöglicht weil der
amerikanische finanzminister nicht
bereit war es mit zu unterschreiben also
auch da war g7 jetzt keine überraschung
die entscheidende frage ist und die
richtet sich ja nicht nur an die
amerikaner sondern auch an die europäer
und damit auch an die deutschen glauben
wir an eine multilaterale ordnung auch
im 21 jahrhundert oder fallen wir zurück
in den nationalismus der ersten hälfte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts und diese
frage die müssen wir auch in deutschland
beantworten mir macht das schon
erhebliches kopfzerbrechen wenn ich höre
auch aus der aus den reihen der eigenen
partei
dass da jetzt gesagt wird die zeit des
multilateralismus seit zu ende
ich glaube dieser gedanke ist nicht zu
ende gedacht was das auch gerade für
deutschland bedeutet sie sind
vorsitzender der atlantik-brücke da
bemüht man sich seit vielen jahrzehnten
darum dieses verhältnis zwischen
deutschland beziehungsweise europa und
den usa nicht nur zu verbessern sondern
auch im zweifelsfall lösungen zu finden
wenn es probleme gibt sie können doch
auf der sagen wir mal obersten
regierungsebene quasi kaum noch
miteinander sprechen wo
wo unterhalb das interessante ist dass
im augenblick auf der regierungsebene in
washington zum teil genau das gegenteil
passiert das was wir so in den medien
und über trump und seine twitter aktion
als völligen isolierung wahrnehmen wird
schon auf der zweiten regierungsebene
deutlich widersprochen indem sie sagen
jetzt müssen wir gerade erst recht
miteinander sprechen
also wir bekommen gesprächs anfragen in
einem umfang wie wir sie vor tom nicht
gehabt haben weil doch eben viele in
washington auch aus der regierung auch
mitarbeiter in der regierung selbst im
weißen haus der meinung sind das kann
man nicht so weiter treiben lassen wir
müssen miteinander reden und sie bemühen
sich auch ton und stil vom inhalt und
der substanz dessen was da gesagt wird
zu unterscheiden und darum bemühe ich
mich auch und wenn man das tut dann
kommt man auch zu dem ergebnis
trump hat ja nicht nur überall unrecht
es gibt ja in balance im warenhandel
zwischen amerika und europa zwischen
amerika und deutschland und darüber muss
man reden dann gibt es andere aspekte
die wir aus deutschland
meines erachtens viel stärker betonen
müssen es gibt ein defizit in unseren
verteidigungsausgaben
wir halten unsere zusagen nicht ein man
kann über die qualität der zusagen
diskutieren ob die nun gut oder richtig
oder falsch sind
darüber kann man diskutieren aber sie
sind abgegeben worden
und dass wir sie nicht einhalten wird in
washington registriert und ich sage mal
ganz einfach so auch hillary clinton
hätte uns manche frage gestellt
höflicher in der form aber nicht weniger
klar in der sache trotzdem noch mal wenn
sie mit amerikanern wenn sie mit
verantwortlichen usa reden auf welcher
ebene findet das jetzt statt und wir
sind da die rückmeldung also zunächst
einmal haben wir natürlich auch in die
administration hinein in die
beamtenschaft hinein sehr gute
beziehungen wir haben auch im state
department im weißen haus nach wie vor
ansprechpartner mit denen wir sprechen
können und die auch darum bemüht sind
mit uns den dialog fortzusetzen
es ist sehr interessant zu beobachten
dass die gouverneure eine größere rolle
beginnen zu spielen
ich nenne auch hier mal ein konkretes
beispiel der uns allen sehr gut bekannte
frühere botschafter
hier in berlin ist jetzt gouverneur in
new jersey geworden phil murphy der mit
großem engagement versucht in der nähe
von new york zwischen new york und
washington gelegen die kontakte auch mit
deutschland aufrecht zu erhalten also es
gibt auch noch das andere amerika aber
vielleicht ist auch unsere wahrnehmung
der auch in den letzten jahren nicht
wirklich richtig gewesen wir sehen
amerika immer über die küsten
die ostküste ist uns vertraut die
westküste ein bisschen auch aber was so
dazwischen liegt die amerikaner sagen
das sind die fly over states also über
die man drüber weg fliegt die man auch
in amerika kaum richtig wahrnimmt aber
da lebt die mehrheit der bevölkerung das
sind auch im zweifelsfall die wähler von
trapp gucken sich die landkarte an die
küsten sind leider sind die farben der
demokraten und das zentrum ist fast
überwiegend bis auf wenige ausnahmen rot
das ist die farbe der republikaner
die republikaner haben im landesinneren
in den usa eine strukturelle mehrheit
vielleicht muss man sogar sagen wir
haben in den letzten jahren und
jahrzehnten glück gehabt immer wieder in
washington regierungen zu haben die
gegen diese mehrheit im inneren
multilaterale politik gemacht haben
einen solchen trend hin zum
unilateralismus america first ist keine
erfindung von trump das hat es auch
schon vorher in den usa gegeben
es ist der erste präsident der das jetzt
zusagen zur überschrift seiner
präsidentschaft macht aber das ist ein
trend den wir in amerika schon seit
jahren wenig seit jahrzehnten sehen
jetzt wollte ich auch mal fragen
friedrich merz und die usa sie sind
jetzt schon sehr lange vorsitzender sehr
intensiv beschäftigen sich natürlich mit
den usa und dem transatlantischen
verhältnis aber wie sind sie zu den usa
als junger mensch gekommen war das noch
so ein bisschen diese vorstellung damals
in den 60er 70er jahren von den riesen
straßenkreuzern und dieser großen
liberalen welt in den usa
nein ich bin sogar relativ spät das
erste mal in meinem leben überhaupt in
amerika gewesen das war im jahr 1987 und
1988 also das ist jetzt gerade mal 30
jahre her dass ich das erste mal dort
war
und da war ich schon mitte 30 ich habe
leider in amerika nie studiert aber mich
hat dieses land immer fasziniert und hat
dann er aus fernsehserien heraus oder
wie haben sie den naja gut also ich sag
mal so als jugendlicher guckt man
natürlich amerikanischen fernsehen
serien das ist keine frage aber ich
hatte die sprache interessiert und
fasziniert mir hat die amerikanische
lebensform immer imponiert nicht alle
formen aber die meisten
ich bin als ich das erste mal in diesem
land gewesen bin begeistert gewesen auch
von der offenheit und von der dynamik
die in diesem land herrscht und ich bin
seitdem ich weiß es nicht
100 mal in amerika gewesen jedes jahr
drei vier fünf sechs mal
ich bin lange zeit auch beruflich mit
amerika verbunden gewesen über eine
große anwaltskanzlei in deren wort ich
gesessen habe ich habe also sozusagen
spät nachgeholt was ich am anfang auch
meine ausbildung nicht machen konnte
weil es damals auch noch gar nicht
üblich war aus meinem semester damals
ist einer von 600 während des studiums
im ausland gewesen heute sind sie als
jemand der nicht im ausland war in der
minderheit
insofern haben sich da auch die zeiten
geändert aber das land fasziniert mich
noch wie vor
wo finden wir denn dann lösungen müssen
wir uns auf eine andere ein anderes
verhältnis zwischen europa und auch
deutschland und den usa einstellen
müssen wenn ich selber auch ein bisschen
klarer sagen was wir wollen
das ist dezidiert meine meinung ich habe
das auch in den letzten tagen und wochen
häufiger auch in der atlantik brücke
selber so gesagt auch in washington
gesagt es gibt im grunde genommen zwei
große herausforderungen die europäer
müssen sich einig sein mit dem was sie
wollen dann sind wir übrigens an
wirtschaftskraft und einwohnern größer
als amerika wenn wir einig wären
und zum zweiten die amerikaner haben
keinen respekt vor gesprächspartnern die
zurückweichen und die sozusagen schon
den kompromiss vor sich her tragen bevor
sie da sind die amerikaner am respekt
vor leuten die ihnen auch mal ganz hart
widersprechen eine dezidiert anderer
meinung haben und das ist meine
erfahrung auch im umgang mit amerikanern
gerade unter freunden muss man in der
lage seien sehr klar sehr deutlich zu
sagen was man meint und wenn das eine
andere auffassung ist dann muss man sie
deutlich zum ausdruck bringen nur so
schafft man sich respekt jetzt hat
natürlich der amerikanische präsident im
augenblick den vorteil die europäer sind
sich nicht einig da gibt es jetzt auch
nicht mehr
vielleicht die klassische konstellation
der letzten jahre bei der eine deutsche
kanzlerin im grunde an der spitze
europas im sinne einer verhandlung für
euro
und eines managements für europa steht
sondern da gibt es im zweifelsfall makro
der viel weiter jetzt für europa sich
eingesetzt hat vier reform bereite auch
ist ist das nicht auch ein europäisches
problem deutschlands politik ist jetzt
seit fast einem jahr durch wahlkampf und
schwierigste regierungsbildung
gehandicapt gewesen
das ist normal diese lange regierungs
bildungs zeit hätte nicht sein müssen
aber dass man in wahlkampfzeiten sich
mehr um die innenpolitik kümmert als um
die außenpolitik ist völlig normal
ich sehe bei den europäern doch immer
noch mehr einigkeit als streit wir sind
uns in den fragen der handelspolitik
weitgehend einig dass wir darauf
reagieren müssen auf das was da aus
amerika kommt wir sind uns auch in der
frage etwa der russland politik nach wie
vor weitgehend einig nennen sie nehmen
sie mal nur das jetzt seit vier jahren
geltende sanktionsregime wegen der
injektion der krim und wegen der ost
ukraine
das verschafft uns in washington respekt
wir müssten allerdings auch in fragen
der verteidigungspolitik der außen und
sicherheitspolitik geschlossener
auftreten
und da ist der ausdruck ausdruck der
briten aus der europäischen union alles
andere als hilfreich
europa verliert mit großbritannien nicht
nur eine von zwei nuklearmächten aus der
europäischen union sondern die zweit
oder dritt größte volkswirtschaft der
europäischen union hans werner sinn hat
man ausgerechnet das ist wäre so als
wenn 19 mitgliedstaaten sozusagen von
unten hoch gerechnet der kleineren
gleichzeitig aus der europäischen union
austreten das was jetzt mit
großbritannien ökonomisch passiert und
das ist natürlich ein schwerer aderlass
für europa schade dass es passiert es
wird wohl passieren aber wir müssen uns
jetzt auf dem kontinent umso mehr zu
sagen sogar ex it beauftragter jetzt
haben wir teuer zahlen das wachstum in
großbritannien ist seit 2009 das
niedrigste im augenblick das heißt man
merkt plötzlich in großbritannien schon
was das wirtschaftlich verurteilt von
politischen strukturen mal abgesehen
was machte eigentlich
also ich helfe der nordrhein
westfälischen landesregierung ein
bisschen die folgen des praxis für das
land nordrhein westfalen so gut wie
möglich zu bewältigen da gibt es ja dann
auch chancen dagegen unternehmen aus
großbritannien raussuchen neue standorte
ich diskutiere mit der dagegen nach
frankfurt ja die banken werden natürlich
er nach frankfurt aus nach düsseldorf
gehen aber industrieunternehmen suchen
standorte auch in industrieregionen
nordrhein westfalen ist die größte
zusammenhängende industrieregionen ganz
europas und da hat mich der
ministerpräsident an schutzgebieten
immer ein bisschen mit rat und tat zur
seite zu stehen das ist eine reine innen
funktion innerhalb der landesregierung
zu helfen ohne bestandteil der
landesregierung zu sein
das mache ich weil ich einfach sehe dass
das konsequenzen hat und es wird zum
teil dramatische konsequenzen gerade für
großbritannien haben aber nicht nur für
großbritanniens hat für ganz europa
werden wir denn davon letztendlich
profitieren und großbritannien
irgendwann an einem punkt stehen und
sagen gott das wären hätten wir das doch
nicht gemacht also meine persönliche
meinung ist mittlerweile die es gibt
keinen weg zurück da sind einfach dinge
in bewegung gekommen und ins rutschen
gekommen wie hält man jetzt nicht mehr
auf bedauerlicherweise ich habe mal
geglaubt das könnte man noch korrigieren
aber das ist wohl nicht so am ende des
tages werden alle schaden nehmen von
dieser entscheidung
der ein oder andere wird auch
profitieren das suchen unternehmen neue
standorte neue arbeitsplätze werden
entstehen da helfe ich in nordrhein
westfalen ein bisschen dazu dass wir
wenigstens bei allem schaden für alle
gibt ein bisschen nutzen dann auch haben
können aber insgesamt politisch wie
ökonomisch ist das ein ziemlich großes
thema in europa in zukunft führen wird
dass eine kanzlerin sein deren macht
situation im augenblick weiter erodiert
oder wird das einmal größeren der im
zweifelsfall auch einige dinge in europa
umsetzen könnte
die wir vielleicht aus deutscher sicht
nicht so gerne möchten also eine
stärkung 242 der südländer
also es wird kein einziges land europa
führen können das war noch nie so und
das wird auch in zukunft nie so seien
die frage ist wer ist der motor der
weiteren europäischen vereinigung makro
hat einige vorschläge auf den tisch
gelegt die bis jetzt mit unzureichender
antwort nur aus deutschland begleitet
werden
das hätte man besser und schneller
machen können sie haben eben gesagt das
liegt ein bisschen daran dass die
regierung des landes versucht auch zu
verstehen oder zu erklären natürlich hat
das auch da sein haben dann haben wir
den konzepte oder haben wir gar nicht
falsch sie hat der falsche gesprächen
einigung im augenblick haben es gibt ja
gar keiner die in der wohl ein
bundeskanzlerin hat ja dazu das eine
oder andere auch schon mal gesagt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat versucht
die ein oder antwort andere antwort zu
geben
der bundesfinanzminister im übrigen ja
auch wir haben mit frankreich nicht nur
einen konsens wichtig ist nur am ende
dass wir ein gemeinsames ziel weiter
haben diese europäische union darf nicht
auseinanderfallen sie darf nicht
auseinanderdriften
wir müssen uns um den kernbestand dessen
besser kümmern was uns gemeinsam stark
macht das ist eine gemeinsame außen und
sicherheitspolitik das ist der
gemeinsame europäische binnenmarkt das
ist auch die währungsunion
aber da gibt es eben viele dinge noch zu
tun um das so zu stabilisieren dass
europa im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
auch zusammenbleibt und mir macht das
schon ein bisschen gedanken wenn ich
höre gerade aus deutschland dass die
zeit jetzt der europa integration und
der des multilateralismus zu ende geht
nein das darf gerade aus deutschland
dürfen solche worte nicht kommen wir
müssen ein wirklich existenzielles
nationales interesse daran haben dass
europa weiter nach vorne kommt und dass
europa stark wird und da muss
deutschland eine ja auch einen
überproportionalen beitrag leisten das
schätzen wir eigentlich immer noch die
asiatische stärke die sich da entwickelt
china und andere länder die im
zweifelsfall in der
wirtschaftsentwicklung in den nächsten
jahrzehnten uns alle überflügelt
offensichtlich ja bei aller begeisterung
für amerika ich empfinde mich als
transatlantiker aber das alleine ist
heute nicht mehr die welt überall da wo
amerika oder europa schwach wird werden
andere stärker es gibt keine es gibt
kein vakuum in der politik in dem
augenblick wo die amerikaner sich aus
dem transpazifischen
partnerschaftsabkommen zurückgezogen
haben haben die chinesen ihre vorschläge
gemacht für eine große transpazifische
handelszone und das projekt dass da
jetzt auf den weg gebracht worden ist
und das ja schon läuft bedeutet im
ergebnis ein drittel der der der
gesamten wirtschaftsleistung der welt
und die hälfte der bevölkerung der welt
finden sich in diesem transpazifische
asiatischen wirtschaftsraum zusammen und
bilden eine freihandelszone wenn das
kommt ist das die größte herausforderung
die amerika und europa gemeinsam jemals
in ihrer jüngeren geschichte erlebt hat
also das heißt umgekehrt gesagt das
transatlantische verhältnis ist
eigentlich wichtiger als je zuvor und
dafür gibt es einen ganz konkreten grund
gar nicht die ökonomischen gründen die
entscheidende frage vor die wir heute
gestellt sind ist doch ganz einfach die
hat unser modell einer offenen
freiheitlichen liberalen toleranten
pluralistischen gesellschaft angesichts
dieser entwicklung noch eine zukunft
oder bekommen die autoritären
politischen systeme sowie china russland
leider auch die türkei mittlerweile so
viel macht dass wir in eine position der
minderheit zurückfallen und nur noch im
verteidigungs- modus sind gegenüber dem
was da unsere freiheit bedroht das ist
für mich im übrigen ja auch die
entscheidende brücke warum ich der
meinung bin dass wir trotz trump mit
amerika weiter engstens zusammenarbeiten
müssen denn die demokratie in amerika
funktioniert der rechtsstaat
funktioniert die pluralität in amerika
funktioniert bei allem was wir da zu
kritisieren haben aber bot müller der
sonderuntersuchung beauftragte der
regierung für die verfehlungen die
möglichen verfehlungen dieser regierung
haben sie sogar schon mal aus moskau
gehört haben so was schon mal aus waging
gehört dass es so etwas gibt in amerika
gibt es sowas so und das sind unsere
gemeinsamkeiten auch im 21
und dafür müssen wir ein bisschen was
tun also dass diese selbstregulierung
auf die man ja jetzt gerade im
zusammenhang mit der mz
wenn man ihre analysen ihrer beurteilung
ihrer beschreibung jetzt sich anhört
merkt man da ist ein mensch der politik
das ist ein durch und durch politischer
mensch der friedrich merz sie sind
ausgeschieden aus der politik aber sie
haben sich nicht ganz zurückgezogen man
kann das offenbar gar nicht ist das eine
droge wie viele reserven die droge
politik die sie morgens immer so ein
bisschen einwerfen wenn man ist doch
nicht nur deswegen ein politischer
mensch war mal mitglied des deutschen
bundestages ist
man kann doch auch ein politischer
mensch sein wenn man in der wirtschafts
verantwortung vielleicht waren sie zu
lange in verantwortlichen positionen im
bundestag etwa als frankreich habe ich
habe meine da nicht mehr raus ich habe
vor meinem eintritt in die politik ein
beruf gehabt ich habe während meiner
politischen amtszeit weitestgehend einen
beruf ausgeübt soweit das eben noch ging
und ich bin danach wieder voll in meinem
beruf zurückgekehrt und deswegen kann
man doch trotzdem ein politisch
denkender mensch hat und vor allen
dingen auch jemand sein der politische
verantwortung ehrenamtlich übernimmt ich
bin ehrenamtlich seit neun jahren
vorsitzender der atlantik-brücke ich
mache das aus überzeugung ich mache das
gerne
aber deswegen ist man doch nicht raus
oder rein das ist doch nicht digital ist
doch nicht einzeln merkt man ihnen an
dass sie da noch mittendrin stecken wenn
man jetzt da drin steckt muss man sich
auch in deutschland viele sorgen machen
um die sagen wir mal konstellation der
politik wir haben eine erosion der
volksparteien wir haben jetzt einen
großen streit innerhalb auch der unions
parteien
was passiert denn da im augenblick haben
wir im zweifelsfall nachher sechs oder
sieben parteien die miteinander kreuz
und wir koalieren und wir haben gar
nicht mehr sozusagen die vertretung des
großen teils der bevölkerung in einer
partei da sind ja zwei fragen die sich
damit verbinden die erste ist
funktionieren die rekrutierungs
mechanismen für die politischen parteien
noch gewinnen die politischen parteien
schlechthin ich nehme sie alle noch
genügend qualifiziertes personal und da
muss man glaube ich mittlerweile sagen
das ist nicht mehr der fall da trägt
übrigens die presse auch ein gehöriges
maß an verantwortung dafür dass dieser
berufsstand des politikers so in
misskredit wir ihn sein aber da haben
die politiker selber mehr beigetragen
als die medien aber dieses ständige
politiker bashing in den medien hat
folgen es gibt mittlerweile und ich
merke im freundes und bekanntenkreis
eine immer geringere zahl von
bürgerinnen und bürgern die bereits ich
sind in der politik zu engagieren das
hängt unten in der kommunalpolitik an
und gehört da gar nicht oben irgendwo in
der bundespolitik auf und das zweite ist
haben die politischen parteien in
deutschland und das sind insbesondere
die beiden großen volksparteien spd und
union noch die kraft und den willen zur
politischen mitte hin zu integrieren
oder gelingt ihnen das nicht mehr
ich nehme mal meine partei von der ich
vielleicht besser beurteilen kann als
von den sozialdemokraten obwohl der
befund für beide identisch ist die
national konservativ denkenden menschen
die es in deutschland immer gegeben hat
zur politischen mitte hin zu integrieren
war eine der großen erfolge der union
wenn man diesen teil der wähler nicht
mehr ernst nimmt wenn man ihn nicht mehr
will oder wenn man ihn vernachlässigt
vielleicht nur aus nachlässigkeit und
hinnimmt dass dann so etwas entsteht wie
die afd
dann ist das ja nicht nur eine
parteipolitische frage sondern dann ist
das eine gesellschaftspolitische frage
ob es gelingt auch verbal menschen die
so denken einigermaßen einzubinden und
auch in ihrer wortwahl etwas zu mäßigen
und da passiert im augenblick und das
beschwert nicht wirklich genau das
gegenteil
die drehen raus und finden ihre existenz
nur noch begründet indem sie jeden tag
an der rhetorischen eskalationsschritt
weiter drehen und das zerstört am ende
des tages unsere demokratie und da haben
beide volksparteien eine aufgabe die
union nach rechts konservativ die spd
nach links wieder zurückzufinden zu
ihrer fähigkeit zur politischen mitte
hin zu integrieren
ich hoffe sehr dass das gelingt in
anderen ländern europas ist es nicht
gelungen und was daraus folgt kommen
dort besichtigen aber der die
bevölkerung hat immer noch einen
besonderen fokus auf das problem der
flüchtlinge auf das problem des asyls
von dem sie den eindruck hat es ist
letztendlich nicht gelöst worden
die zahlen sind weitaus niedriger als in
den letzten jahren
trotzdem ist in der bevölkerung die
sensibilität nicht gesunken sondern man
hat er noch mehr das problem
wir wissen ja gar nicht was da passiert
ist dann kommen solche dinge wie die
krise oder der skandal um bump jetzt
eine große diskussion innerhalb der
union um die frage relativ kleiner
unterscheidungen
bei dem asylrecht bei den möglichkeiten
flüchtlinge abzuhalten
diese sensibilität wird aber offenbar
nicht richtig aufgenommen von den
politischen das weiß ich nicht ich will
mir da auch von außen kein urteil
abschließend erlauben weil ich auch
nicht alle details kenne auch die
hintergründe um das band nicht nur in
der wirkung ist doch klar wenn die
bevölkerung das gefühl hat dass der
rechtsstaat nicht mehr funktioniert dass
da dinge außer kontrolle geraten
dann hat das erhebliche folgen auf das
vertrauen der bevölkerung und
letztendlich auch auf das
wählerverhalten der bevölkerung und das
was da im augenblick passiert in der
diskussion innerhalb der union führt ja
nicht etwa dazu dass die wähler einen
großen zahlen zurück kommen zur union
und sagen endlich diskutiert hier mal
über dieses thema das gegenteil tritt
ein
die umfrage gehen nach unten auch für
die csu in bayern
und da muss sich die union sehr genau
überlegen ob sie diesen streit
fortsetzen will und den eindruck
erwecken will ich weiß gar nicht ob es
tatsächlich so ist aber den eindruck
erwecken will dass da bestimmte dinge
nicht mehr wirklich unter kontrolle sind
und das zerstört auch das vertrauen in
unseren rechtsstaat in der zeit ihrer
verantwortungsvollen funktionen der
politik haben sie auch immer wieder
festgestellt das was die bevölkerung
nicht möchte ist streit
sie will eine auseinandersetzung um die
sache aber sie will keinen persönlichen
strahls dass das ist genau das was wir
im augenblick empfinden da streiten sich
in der union die verantwortlichen
politiker das führt aber dann
letztendlich dazu dass eine union auch
immer schwächer wird
gibt es da eine perspektive aus ihrer
sicht wie sich das weiter entwickeln
kann auch da will ich das sogar schon
von außen keine ratschläge geben am ende
stimme ich ihnen in einer analyse zu
streit um die sache gehört zur
demokratie streit um die personen
beschädigt die demokratie wenn wir in
der sache unterschiedlicher meinung sind
dann muss man das offen austragen
aber dann muss man auch wissen worum es
geht also ich fühle mich als
zeitungsleser und als mitglied dieser
partei nicht ausreichend informiert wenn
ich nicht weiß was in 63 punkten
ein migrations und einwanderungs konzept
drin steht
da wird über ein papier diskutiert das
nicht veröffentlicht wird alleine dieser
sachverhalt führt doch zu unnötiger
verärgerung auch in der bevölkerung und
da muss ich sagen das trägt nicht dazu
bei dass die glaubwürdigkeit der politik
steigt und auch weniger kann man
verstehen dass 62 eineinhalb punkte wie
horst seehofer das gesagt hat eigentlich
gelöst sind ein halber punkt nicht und
damit an ringstraße ich kann dazu gar
nichts sagen wie wie offensichtlich auch
80 millionen deutsche auch nicht denn
wir kennen alle dieses papier nicht um
das da so heftig gestritten wird auch
das ist doch im grunde genommen ein
völlig bizarre vorgang
trotzdem ist das was sie als
zeitungsleser sagen sie zurückhaltend
aber letztendlich auch als mensch der
politik sehen und beurteilen und
analysieren dann doch immer wieder etwas
was sie anregt wo sie sich nicht
raushalten wollen wo sie dann im zweifel
zwar noch eine sehr klare meinung zu
haben ist das ein schwieriger spagat den
sie eingehen
nein warum soll das so schwierig sein
ich kann doch ich kann doch eine
persönliche klare meinung haben ohne
dass gleich mit politischen ämtern
verbinden zu müssen und zu wollen ich
meine staatsbürgerschaft dieses landes
und habe mir eine eigene meinung dass
sollen sie ja um gottes willen deswegen
frage ich sehe aber auf der anderen
seite haben sie ja sehr klar gesagt was
fehlt es ja in den letzten jahren eine
klare konservative struktur und kontur
auch letztendlich eine konservative
kultur in der cdu warum ist die nicht
mehr gewollt oder nicht mehr entstanden
hat die kanzlerin was ihr vorgeworfen
wird die spd vereinnahmt in dem sie
eigentlich sozialdemokraten geworden
und auch da bin ich der falsche adressat
frage ich beobachte die dinge und und
stelle einfach fest dass sich da im
politischen parteienspektrum in letzten
jahren etwas verändert hat und mich
erfüllt das mit einiger verwunderung
will ich sagen verärgerung aber doch mit
großem erstaunen dass das einfach
hingenommen wird dass da jetzt mit 12,6
prozent rechts von der union eine
politische partei sich etabliert von der
auch die umfragen die umfrageinstitute
sagen
da könnte er nur maximal die hälfte von
zurückgewinnen der rest hat sich da fest
etabliert alleine diese tatsache müsste
doch eigentlich zu größerer
nachdenklichkeit führen ich würde das
nicht gerne als einfach hingenommen und
gott gegeben ansehen dass das so ist das
war nicht nötig wenn wir diese
konservative kontur hätten war der cdu
sind sie einigermaßen sicher dass wir
damit eine sehr viel schwächere afd
hätten bzw dass das protest verhalten
was offenbar dort sich auch eine stimme
gibt nicht so aber das ist ja keine
frage der konservativen struktur ja oder
nein denn es ist eine frage der
integrationsbereitschaft und fähigkeit
auch um diese themen sollen die cdu ist
immer und deswegen bin ich 1972
eingetreten diese partei ist eine
soziale partei eine liberale partei und
eine konservative partei zumindest
gewesen und war immer bereit eben in
einem größeren spektrum zur politischen
mitte hin zu integrieren
diesen anspruch hat die cdu in den
letzten jahren aus meiner sicht als
einfaches mitglied nicht mehr genügend
auch gezeigt und gelebt man muss zur
politischen mitte hin integrieren wollen
der spd gelingt das und ich sage das
ohne schadenfreude erkennbar auch nicht
mehr
und frau wagenknecht hat ja bei aller
unterschiedlichkeit in den politischen
positionen mit dem was sie da sagt nicht
unrecht dass es auf der linken
irgendetwas geben muss was diese
spaltung von linkspartei und spd wieder
überwindet wenn das nicht kommt sind
diese beiden politischen parteien für
jahre wenn nicht jahrzehnte
regierungsunfähig so und genau das selbe
findet sozusagen auf der anderen
straßenseite statt und ich möchte
einfach nicht sehen dass wir eine solche
fragmentierte parteienlandschaft haben
wie in anderen ländern
diese zerstörung der politischen
strukturen geht einher mit einer
gefährdung der demokratie und das ist
eigentlich das thema das jenseits aller
parteipolitik liegt er märz würden sie
für alle zeiten zumindest ihres lebens
ausschließen dass sie nochmal in die
politik zu gehen uns die frage stellen
ich habe immer gesagt ich habe mich 2009
bewusst entschieden zurück in den beruf
zu gehen ich habe 20 jahre aktiv in der
politik
gearbeitet das hat mir überwiegend große
freude gemacht ich mache das heute
ehrenamtlich an der einen oder anderen
stelle und ich habe keine veranlassung
über irgendetwas nachzudenken
ich hoffe dass mein leben noch relativ
lange dauert und was das dann bringt
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich weder heute noch
morgen
märz kratzer sehen dank für das gespräch
bedanken
[Musik]